Emmie peas old and new arrived in
Parliament hot foot from elections in
which the political temperature shifted
to new extremes on the right and left
their task to reconstitute the seven
existing political groups try to form a
new one in the case of marine lepen and
then jockey for influential positions
within Parliament is a very hectic time
political groups should be established
by the first of your life so that then
the process of dividing sort of say the
committee's presidencies for the
different groups will will start but
these things can't be rushed after all
members of groups will have to live with
each other's policies and views for the
next five years of important European
law making no no no that's the work then
the declaration afterwards the elections
delivered a hundred and two non-aligned
members including in France marine lepen
sessional front which one 24 seats it's
by no means certain that she will be
able to form a group with at least 25
members from seven countries but if she
does will fellow mep s work with her I'm
not of their political ideology but for
the dynamics in European Parliament I
think it's better that they form also a
group the engine of the European
Parliament are still the Christian
Democrats and the Social Democrats the
more groups you have that doesn't
necessarily mean you have more democracy
democracy is also an issue of content
and I don't consider more independent
Democrat I don't welcome her it's as yet
unclear what groups will be formed and
if indeed the anti-european and populist
forces will be able and willing to form
a group I actually would welcome if they
form a group not because I like their
ideas I want to enter into a debate with
them the first chance to test that will
be in the first session of the new
Parliament in Strasbourg in July